some breaking news just into our  newsroom from the clark county school  district effective june  1st adjustments to the mask policy we've  been waiting for this  so we know that all staff who are fully  vaccinated as of june 1st  no longer required to wear a mask on  campus but they must on school buses  as for students masks will be optional  for students pre-k  through grade three masks required for  students grade four  and five and masks optional for students  grades six  through twelve who have been fully  vaccinated now students and staff do not  have to wear masks outdoors  again this is effective as of june 1st  the school year this school year ends  on wednesday so that will be for the  summer and for the upcoming school year